apocryphal story and just exaggerated
better a door than a coffin with the
clintons yes did any of your candidates
like the brakes go out in their cars or
anything like that Republican candidates
in Arkansas you're gonna wake up with a
horse head and you're in your bed so
glad to have this next guest full
disclosure I've known him for a while
I'd like to consider him a friend so
before people get in a comment section
and go hey you should one for your
friend we've had several candidates on
you can find him at Mike Huckabee
dot-com not the dot-org business
Governor Mike Huckabee thanks for coming
on I my pleasure Stephen and you know I
love some of the things you're doing I
was talking before you even came into
the room some of the hilarious things
you did I mean there were serious but
they were Alerus where you walked into
Muslim bakeries and asked to make a
same-sex wedding cake for you and I
thought it just pointed out the other
hypocrisy of the left and being very
selective that they're outraged that
Christians would follow their
convictions but it's perfectly okay
right Muslims off there's Welk anyway
just like the many of of that empirical
if you're running for president to say
that you like anything I've put out I
don't want you don't want that kind of
heat well that's true it is true well
it's funny about that one I mean you
know they always say well this is
selectively edited well of course I'm a
comedian and that was selectively edited
to be funny and I said like there were
some Muslim bakeries you were very nice
and there were some who weren't but it
only takes one lawsuit and that's the
point right and you were talking about
that with with Kim Davis right off the
bat firstly so right after the debates
how are you feeling it's unanimously
people seem to really think you had a
good performance well I mean I think
given the questions I had I would have
loved to have had more substantive
questions about things like the Fair Tax
I'd have liked to have talked more about
what is it that makes a person prepare
to be president right I mean I really
think we win we miss in these debates an
opportunity to sort of delve into the
character the background the
preparedness of somebody to be President
it's a pretty serious job I don't think
it's entry level I think a person needs
to have had that kind of experience so
that when you're president you're gonna
face not what you expect you're gonna
face what you don't accept
right and that's what you're really
elected to be ready for well but you
didn't expect those moderators to be I
mean that I I hate to do the whole media
bias because I'm just overplayed but
that was in my opinion the worst leftist
hatchet job I've ever seen in the
history of tonight do you think I'm out
of line with that assessment
you're not interestingly Stephen even
the left-wing media I mean you had
articles on Politico they were just
savaging the process of the debate last
night of the way that CNBC handled but
first of all I mean let me give a little
sort of behind-the-scenes thing that a
lot of people probably won't know yes we
love the SEC had had told all the
campaign's that they were going to make
sure that we had a very different
experience and that they were going to
equitably distribute the time that they
had some algorithms that they had
carefully built that were gonna tell him
exactly where they were which candidate
had the most questions which one needed
to have more they were going to take
care of this do you think that happened
last night I'm going to tell you it must
have been al gore rythms because there
was nothing in there that was balanced
and fair not only about the amount of
time allocated but also about the type
of questions and even when they were
spaced out so I just feel like that the
RNC has got to get on top of this
process this is not a game show right
this is not a process to let America be
entertained by watching some people take
cheap shots at Republican candidates who
whether they like us or not we have put
our lives on the line to run for
president it's a serious process for
every single one of us right and the
kind of questions that were asked last
night very different than the ones that
were asked well in Las Vegas to the
Democratic candidates for me the jumping
the shark moment I don't know about for
you but it was really bad and I
appreciate that Cruz went after them and
and you know people really like that for
me the shark jumping moment was when
they asked Carson they said you know you
said you were on the board at Costco and
they were rated as a super gay friendly
or organization how do you justify that
like we care that Carson what if I buy a
rotisserie chicken at Costco and they
have a gay romance novel what does that
have to do with running for president
it was a ridiculous question you know
I've often said that the difference
between people like me who are very
committed Christians who believe in
traditional marriage and people on the
left is that I'm very accepting and
tolerant and people who have a different
point of view right I use an iPhone and
a MacBook and an iPad
even though Tim Cook is certainly not
friendly to my point of view on marriage
right
I drink Starbucks coffee and our order
stuff on Amazon well guess what all of
the ceos of those companies support a
view of marriage that I absolutely don't
support but you know what I don't try to
put them out of business over it but you
know might have other entities in which
if a Christian stands up then there's
going to be a concerted effort not just
to disagree with them but to put them
out of business and I don't think that
whole dichotomy has been explored very
much and certainly not by the mainstream
press well no and they try and act as
though well you know actually have a
funny story about that so I went into
this is I was working at Fox News know
for a few years and at this point I was
still an actor kind of auditioning so I
was auditioning for a sports show and I
went in and it was at a screen test
point where they were rotating us you
know they bro taped the panel and there
was a guy in there and the second he
found out Fox News he's a liberal
podcaster he liked his brain exploded
and he was saying like Oh which shows do
you do when I mentioned your name I said
you know governor Huckabee show and I
started talking when she hated you and I
said you know what I said you know what
about Governor Huckabee I know what
people think I said but he's actually
really he actually be a really genuinely
funny guy and this was a few years ago
and I remember his response he said
what's funny about him his views on gay
marriage and I looked at him right in
the face and I said you mean the exact
same views as Barack Obama because at
that point he hadn't shifted yet so it's
it's amazing how quickly people forget
it and they vilify someone like you as
this crazy
you know Westboro Baptist just for
having an opinion well it's part of the
I think challenge that we face as
conservatives and and more specifically
if we're Christian conservatives but you
know I've got a pretty
I guess just laissez-faire attitude to
say I can't make these people like me
right there's something in them it's not
in me I don't hate anyone but some of
them really do have a lot of hate there
is no tolerance they have
no place for diversity they talk about
diversity tolerance and love but I'll
tell you the meanest people I've ever
met or people who are activists or a
point of view on the left and they just
can't stand that everyone doesn't agree
with them right and there's no sense of
humor there's no sense of hmm that's an
interesting thought maybe maybe we
should converse more right but that's
that's the nature of the beast we're
living with right now well I I said this
because listen let's be honest you're
you know you're and I don't mean older
white guys what people will say you know
but I am okay but let's contrast what
let's say you know Carly Fiorina who's a
woman Latinos in the stage ben Carson
and I said listen ben Carson is a
neurosurgeon you may not agree with him
but he's a neurosurgeon and he's a black
guy from Detroit to a single mother okay
if we're gonna talk about the black
experience he's not playing for the B
team that's the MVP Detroit single
mother let's be honest I said if they
paint him as a racist dummy which is
what they've done they're gonna do it
with anyone it doesn't matter if it's
governor Mike Huckabee or Ben Carson or
Ted Cruz or Carly Fiorina so I think
what a lot of people like me regardless
of who wins the nomination we just want
to see conservatives and Republicans
stop preemptively apologizing because
they're gonna do it anyway well and I
think one of the things that you've seen
in all these debates is none of us are
backing down none of us are just saying
yeah we we're so sorry we've offended
somebody I think all of us are stepping
up and saying we offended you gee you've
got a problem I don't right and and
moving on and and not allowing ourselves
to be beaten into this submission to the
far left and be made out to be something
we're not which look we're thoughtful
serious guys most everybody on this
stage is very well educated and I'm
gonna tell you something I I don't know
of anyone this is what I try to convey
last night when I was thrown debate
about Trump everybody on that stage I've
got more confidence in being president
than I do Hillary Clinton Bernie Sanders
or martin O'Malley
I mean come on give me a break oh come
on you don't need a mention martin
O'Malley need to throw that name in
there it should Hillary be frog-marched
a federal courthouse lawn for federal
charges which won't happen under this
administration but I mean should that
happen Martens there to pick up the
slack
I think it's Sanders I think a lot of
conservatives and Republicans have
underestimated the Sanders effect and
I've we've gotten a lot of flack because
I've done a lot of videos on it and were
the only Republicans only conservatives
out there who've done anything and
what's very funny is a lot of the Ron
Paul supporters were courted and some of
them didn't but about half of them did
jump to Bernie Sanders and it doesn't
compute well in a way it kind of does
often said that when I was you know and
I was in a campaign eight years ago
against Ron Paul very sincere guy and I
liked him a lot yeah but I sometimes
said if he went to one of his rallies it
was sort of half gun show half Grateful
Dead concert you know an interesting mix
of people who are really angry at the
government I think Bernie Sanders has
tapped into sort of the left anger in a
way that some candidates tap into the
right anger Trump but I also believe
well in many ways yeah yeah but I do
think that he could be a George McGovern
of this cycle a person that is so far
left nobody thinks he can win but
there's just such a mood within the
Democratic Party they want someone who
really represents just how left-wing
they have become and the fact that he is
doing so well is really indicative of
what has happened to the Democratic
Party there are no scoop Jackson's
anymore that are defense Hawks that
really believe in protecting the
national security that's right this
country I mean that's good good thing to
think about is that but just go back to
Jim Webb the one guy on that stage among
the Democrats who had military
experience who had national security
experience and you know they basically
tossed him overboard yeah well I don't
know if I wrote about this not only
obviously the the diversity that the
left loves which I just can't stand
diversity there happens or doesn't it
shouldn't be government and force but on
the Republican stage you've got this
intellectual diversity of you know Rand
Paul who's all about that cannabis oil
and then chris Christie who's really
more of a almost of a war hawk and
you've got you're seen as more of a
conservative sort of social concern
Christian and then he got Fiorina who
would be somewhere in the middle there's
such there's such a wide spectrum and on
the left when you watch those debates
the only disagreement they had was over
who had the lowest rating from the NRA
that was the biggest argument they had
and and that's why I think Bernie
Sanders when it comes to the general he
only had a d-minus and the gun issue is
such a losing issue for the left and
Hillary Clinton is seen as so shrill an
anti-gun I think that's a tough hurdle
for her III think you could be right and
you may be the first person to predict
that Bernie Sanders would be the nominee
but I think it's very possible because
Bernie Sanders has tapped into that anti
corporate anti-wall Street feeling by
the way I share some of that because I
think that Republicans are as guilty as
the Democrats and they take all the
money from these big donors and they do
their bidding
when people give those kind of dollars
to a campaign they're not doing it with
an altruistic spirit they're doing it
with an expectation that when they want
something they're going to be able to
get their favors returned right and I do
think the system is broken Bernie
Sanders is at least right on that but it
goes back to the theory that even a
broken clock is Right twice a day this
is well this is true and what's funny is
you know the tea party when it came
first around and I you know their whole
thing was the Rick Santelli rant the
anti Wall Street bailout that's how it
started and then occupy happened and it
was the same thing only in sort of
peaceful protests people were getting
sexually accosted in tents in Zuccotti
Park but there was common ground there
people for some reason it's seen as a
Republican idea that we should bail out
big banks when if you read any of the
big books from concerns whether it's
Seoul whether it's John Stossel
even when there's people who people
think are crazy whether it's whether
it's Beck or Limbaugh people who
mainstream America have vilified they've
all been against those bailouts so I
want to kind of throw that to you you're
seen is more of a social conservative
candidate and one of the criticisms
would be from people you're not fiscally
oh wait we only have one minute Jared
well you know what we'll set this up and
then we'll come back from this we go go
to the next segment because you need the
floor on this all right but there are
some people who obviously lob that
you're not fiscally conservative so
before we go to the break would you say
yay or nay I would say I'm very fiscally
conservative and I've got a record too
prove it and I hope we get a chance to
talk about it we will we're gonna go to
our evil corporate overlords for
advertising and we'll be back with
Governor Mike Huckabee and we are back
with governor Mike Huckabee thank you so
much for staying with us so like right
to be here
before the break some people say you're
kind of the social conservative
candidate right now fiscally and go
ahead and give them your pitch
well I cut taxes nearly a hundred times
in Arkansas and I did that against the
headwinds of a legislature that was 90
percent Democrat nobody in the country
nobody not somebody from Massachusetts
Vermont Maine New Jersey Oregon or
California ever had a legislature as LOB
shot at his mind yet we not only cut
taxes we transformed our state's economy
and brought the basic per capita income
up about 50 percent over the course of
my time I oppose tarp when a lot of
Republicans were out there saying
wringing their hands oh we just have to
do and I said no you don't that's not a
conservative principle I have fought for
the FairTax which is the most
conservative approach to taxation that
exists because it doesn't penalize
people's productivity and subsidize your
responsibility our reformed welfare in
our state we took half the people off of
welfare got them into jobs cut those
roles by 50% you know I put my record
fiscally up against anybody's but more
importantly keep it in the context of
the kind of atmosphere in which I had to
govern could I have done even more and I
had a even a 60% or a 51% Republican
legislature yeah but I had a 10%
Republican legislature and a 90%
Democrat legislature all of him by the
way where Clinton Easter's and all
indebted to the Clinton political
machine that was the atmosphere in which
I governed Arkansas
well you even eluded that last night
that you got out alive is there more
subtext there than I need to know
governor because I've talked about this
for a while I'll just leave it at that
try to point out is that while a lot of
candidates say you know I'm the best to
go against Hillary Clinton the
difference is none of them have ever
actually done it
bill and Hilary both came to Arkansas
campaign for every opponent I ever had
they recruited most of those candidates
who ran against me they raised the money
for them you have no idea what it's like
to inherit a state government that is so
hostile that when I went to open my door
as lieutenant governor first elected it
wouldn't open and the reason web hubbell
who was working at the White House in
one of Hillary's former law partners had
called the Secretary of State and said
nail his door shut and they did so my
door was nailed shut
with thrill nails and it stayed that way
for my first 59 days as the elected
lieutenant governor of the state I hear
some of the Republicans say I'm a
fighter people are going to call BS on
that we have to have a source I could
have someone send it to us because it
sounds unbelievable but I believe you
well I'm giving you a source John fund
wrote in The Wall Street Journal about
this okay after it happened go back to
July 1993 because the Wall Street
Journal didn't think it was true they
thought it was in a sort of an
apocryphal story and just exaggerated
better a door than a coffin and talked
with the Clintons yes did any of your
candidates like the brakes go out in
their cars or anything like that
Republican candidates in Arkansas you're
gonna wake up with a horse head and
you're in your bed I mean listen I
wouldn't put it and I don't say that
about a lot of people I don't say it
about Barack Obama Bernie Sanders I'm
not a conspiracy guy but when you look
at some of the things that the Clintons
have done and it's it's it's not a
difference of opinion it's criminal it
really is and that's my opinion
I don't want to ascribe that to you but
that's what's so scary about it let me
ask you this really quickly you tweeted
something out and what's funny is I me
to do research where you said you would
trust was it the Clintons Bernie with
his taxes what was a quote that the the
North Col I said I would rather trust a
North Korean chef with my Labrador than
I would to have to trust Bernie Sanders
with the tax code yes except you said in
reverse because Labrador was the
punchline yeah right because you know
how to frame jokes I've seen you do it I
thought like everyone got so mad I
thought oh no he screwed up because I
know the dogs in China and Vietnam so I
was like well maybe he screwed up and
people are going to
and I looked it up no they eat dogs in
Korea um yeah why do you think people
were so upset when it's so clearly
factually accurate well because you have
to understand the left doesn't care what
the facts are they manufacture their
offenses and so even if there's nothing
to be offended about they can pretend
that they're offended so they can try to
demand an apology demand a retraction
and you know what for far too long
conservatives have tried to be so
accommodating oh well I shouldn't have
said it that way it was inartful no I've
just said it's exactly what I meant to
say I said it because I thought it was
funny and if you don't think it's funny
then you know what don't listen to me
but I'm not going to stop a sense of
humor and I'm not going to even stop
talking factual things that are the
basis of humor because it offends
somebody who really isn't offended
Steven this is the part the point
they're not really offended but they
pretend they are because if they ever
had to debate the substance of the
issues they know they would lose they
cannot stand to deal with the logical
conclusion of their own irrational
points of view for future reference a
good tag to that would be or the White
House chef because of course our
president a dog as well want to make
sure we get that he admitted the whole
point about the North Korea there was in
North Korea they're eating lawn
clippings and the barks off trees
because unless you're in the military
you're starving to death under this
dictator communist regime and that was
really the point to be made yeah but he
got 16 holes in one and his first game
of the weird stuff they made him out to
be a daddy well his dad they were like
he got 16 holes in one in a first game
of golf I'm like something better if
you're gonna try and lie to you Bob Lake
like why go golf yes it's it's a rough
deal that's one of those perfect
contrasts North Korea South Korea you
ever see a satellite map of the lights
at night between the two I have and it's
just I mean that is the most revealing
thing and I've been to the you know to
the border I've stood there right at the
DMZ you're looking over into North Korea
and it is just a I don't know a chilling
reminder of what communism is all about
and how evil it really is let me ask you
this a lot of people say you know you're
a real longshot candidate right
if you kind of look at the national
polls it's been sort of the Trump show
and then Carson sort of surged so what
do you say to those people staying in
chugging along why well because four
years ago everybody but Herman Cain was
supposed to get out because he was
leading the polls eight years ago
everybody but Rudy Giuliani was supposed
to get out because at this time in the
election he was leading in the polls now
let me ask you this if he rolled the
calendar back four months was there any
national pundit who predicted that
Donald Trump and ben Carson would be
fighting it out for the leading position
in the polls at this point
not one single pundit in America said
that they were 100% wrong about where
the race would be now what makes us
think they're a hundred percent right or
even 20 percent right about where the
race is going to be in February when the
first votes are cast hold on one second
governor we have to go we have a hard
break and then we'll let you come on
real quick governor Mike Huckabee
dot-com you want to hear him finish this
up go to the web extended version at
loud or with or web extended you can say
whatever you want finish your thought
governor please well I think sometimes
people put so much stock in these polls
and they make it as if that is a
predictor of where things are going to
come in Iowa I got more votes than any
person ever has in the entire history of
the Iowa caucus members and we are far
ahead now of where we were eight years
ago but there's one thing I do know I
know how to win those caucuses and you
don't win it by polls in November you
win it by organizing and having a great
ground game and building out the
activists one of the time so we're
comfortable where we are where we're
going and where we will be at the
election okay one quick question for the
libertarians who are skeptical a lot of
them who watch this show
what's a governor Huckabee presidency
like for them they're afraid you're
going to come in and you know enforce
Christian martial law
that's ridiculous I mean I believe the
best government is the most limited and
be most local that's how it was supposed
to be the reason we have government that
we have is because if people don't live
up to that golden rule of do unto others
as you would have them do unto you and
so people even though they say they
don't want government let somebody break
into their home and what do they say I
want more cops on my street well that's
more government so
there's a lot of hypocrisy where people
say they don't want it but I'd like as
little as we could get by with but in
order for that to happen we have to have
people who live by the golden rule and
we have to have people that govern
themselves so they don't have to have a
bunch of government on top of them and
that is tough to do well governor
Huckabee thank you so much for the time
the site is Mike Huckabee com my
Christmas right Mike Huckabee calm and
Steven great to be with you today
thank you sir and Godspeed with the
elections we'll be keeping a close eye
on it you like this video you can watch
these other videos more importantly
click my face to go straight to my
website and enter to win in ar-15 it
ends November 14th that's right we're
giving away a free ar-15 some of you
asking why well the camera sold well
it's a question that's silly and I won't
respond to it